Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday,
June mm seventies
2019.
What's going on out?
How are you everybody happy belated father's Day to you.
Happy belated father's day to you.
Woo Woo,
Woo.
Happy Belated suthers day to all the dads.
You probably didn't get shipped it.
Okay.
Happy belated father's day to everybody.
I'm actually recording this on father's day,
so I have no idea what my father's day is going to be.
I think it's going to be a good one.
I'm doing the podcast earlier because,
uh,
my lovely families taken me and my father on law outflow.
Nice fucking steak dinner or with a killing the cows that I said I was going to
try to stop eating.
I was going to eat a little bit less,
you know,
and then what do you do?
Am I going to eat fish?
The fish are all going away.
And then I read in that Howard Stern,
uh,
interview in rolling stone dead.
His white cell count.
I forget if it,
if it goes up or down,
I forget what it was.
And they thought he had cancer and they were going to give them chemotherapy and
it turned out he was eating too much fucking fish and the and all kinds of
things.
Yet,
although this fucking mercury in them,
they almost gave him chemo.
So I what,
what can you eat?
They'll fuck.
Can you eat anymore?
Um,
I dunno.
I just try to eat.
I try to switch it up.
I try to hope one carcinogen,
knocks out the other carcinogen that's in my food and then I just do the
elliptical.
That has been my game plan.
Um,
I went down to the cellar last night,
Saturday night,
Saturday.
I did one spot at the original than I did the fat black pussy cat upstairs.
And then downstairs I did the village underground and um,
I came walking in right.
And I'd already eaten healthy and I came walking in in the seller has really
healthy food.
The Olive Tree upstairs.
So Mike,
okay.
Worst case scenario,
get like a chicken Kebab.
A little to hear.
Um,
what do you call that?
That super chopped up the fucking salad.
Not Tahini.
That's the sauce.
Uh,
not Tiki.
Marcella,
I don't what the fuck you call it.
I forget what it is.
Um,
I was going to get one of those salads and then I walked in lemonade,
ordered out for Joe's pizza and they had four delicious large cheese or
Pepperoni fucking pizzas and uh,
they're like,
have a slice of a slice.
I'm like,
I can't,
I have an acting gig.
It sucked.
That's what kills me is I'm gonna have to try to cram all my pizza eating,
you know,
I went off the rails and the Bruins lost,
uh,
the Stanley Cup game seven,
but even then I only have one slice,
but they had all this great stuff and I laid off,
I laid off,
I stayed with the waters and I proceeded to have three of the most fun fucking
shows I've had in a long time.
And I'll tell you,
is all the great I get to do in this business.
I swear to God,
nothing.
Nothing.
Nothing is more fun than doing stand up comedy and trying a new bit and having
it work.
There is nothing in this fucking business of shoe is they say that is more
fucking satisfying and exciting than that.
And um,
I finally got the abortion thing to work.
I stopped opening with it so I just got it.
I moved it down a little bit.
So they just saw I was sort of silly and then I went into it and um,
I just had three fucking great shows the night before I was at the west side
comedy club had a great set there and um,
cause I'm going to be in Pittsburgh here in a few weeks and I got to come with
all the new shit even though,
uh,
my special hasn't come out yet.
I feel like our,
I did Pittsburgh on this run and I don't want to a,
I don't know,
just in case somebody is a repeat customer,
you know what I mean?
I don't want to come back with the same shit is what the fuck I'm saying.
So,
and being out here in New York,
it's really making me want to come out here every summer for a couple of weeks
and just do a bunch of spots.
Um,
take my wife to a bunch of cool stuff.
So at some point I gotta walk my Kiddo.
I,
whenever I go to New York,
I always have to do the walk across the Brooklyn Bridge,
so I still have to do that.
And,
uh,
there's a couple other things,
but I'm laying off the smokes now.
Um,
I got four days laying off that I'm going to try and go back to how I used to
be,
which is I smoked one every two weeks and I was beyond looking forward to it.
Um,
yeah,
it's just with father's day and my birthday people bought me a couple of boxes
of cigars and I'm Kinda like,
well,
what am I supposed to do here?
I don't want these to go bad.
Right.
I mean,
I got a smoke them probably hand a few off to my friends is what the fuck I
should be doing.
But,
um,
I don't know if there's always something you gotta be working on in your life.
And it made my life is like fucking perfect right now.
I've got a great acting gig.
I'm in New York.
I can do my stand up.
My family's here,
I'm playing drums.
The weather has been nice.
It hasn't gotten ridiculously hot yet.
It's just been absolutely fucking perfect.
And today I'm going to do my podcast early and I'm going to hang around and I'll
watch the rest of the u s open.
I watched a little bit yesterday watching Rory and all these guys and fucking
tiger and Phil Mickelson and all the younger kids who I don't even know who the
hell they are.
I just got in,
I was just like,
you know what?
It's so hard when the NHL and the NBA stopped those fast paced things,
then all of a sudden just like,
you know,
pull the emergency brake and try to get into baseball.
You know?
But so I go,
I'm going to go even further into a slowed down sport and I'm going to fuck it.
I'm going to watch golf.
Cause then baseball was,
seemed fast paced.
So that's what I did yesterday.
I,
I laid on the couch,
I watched it.
I took an old man nap,
I think I fell asleep on that guy was trying to,
[inaudible] was in the rough and there was a little fucking flower and there was
a bee on it and he didn't want to swing the club and kill the bee,
you know,
which back in the day they would have just blasted right through it.
And you wouldn't have known because there was no HDTV.
I don't think Peter had the fucking strength that they have now,
but you know the bs of going away.
So I think that guy,
you know,
he did was stinking environmentally.
You know,
granted he swung the club and killed the fucking flower.
Um,
what's going to happen that day?
Uh,
vegetarians realize that plants feel pain.
Then what are they going to eat
if all of a sudden we come up with something that we can actually read their
thoughts?
Like that flower was just sitting there yelling at the be,
don't leave me dog Joe Lake Bay.
Yeah.
Like that guy.
God,
Jack Dog,
Giotto this in 48 hours.
Tell him to be,
not to leave,
don't hand them the gun over.
Um,
which by the way,
in all of cinema had to have been the worst cop moment ever.
When he gives his fucking gun away,
there's,
I don't know anything about police being a policeman,
but there's no fucking way you turn your gun over when he has a gun on a hostage
and the zone,
a cop there without a fucking gun.
Uh,
but anyway,
uh,
so the,
the fucking flowers probably sitting there yelling at the bait,
all Amy dog,
Giotto,
it,
and he takes off and he's just sitting there wanting to run in a cat.
This guy just swings the club back,
all the other flowers trying to look the other way.
Like,
yeah,
you hate to say it day to fucking see it,
but you know something,
a lot of nature is getting eaten alive.
There's a lot of fucking horrible ways to go.
You just get eaten.
You know,
I remember thinking,
get eaten by a lion would be terrible.
And now when I watch it,
it's not that bad.
You know,
I've seen a few people getting eaten by tigers and shit.
They just put,
once they grab you around the neck,
which is immediately you just pass out,
you know,
just like in the UFC,
except it's like the fucking tiger level strength.
It's fucking over a law.
That was one guy who was sort of kicking at another tiger.
This pathetic.
He tried to sneak into the fucking zoo.
How much is the zoo?
You know,
30,
40 bucks.
And where he scaled and jumped over the wall was the fucking tiger.
Yeah.
Layer enclave.
Uh,
what the fuck did they call those?
A condo.
Fucking areas.
Right.
And he fucking landed.
Hit the fucking didn't look first,
did not look before he leaves because he was doing something illegal.
And he landed and he was in the fucking,
he was in the fucking tiger and closure.
And uh,
they don't have any guns over there.
I'm sure they brought that up at one of those fucking second amendment.
Is that one of this?
Is that the second amendment?
The right to bear arms that you're on now out there was America to shot that
fucking dog around the FYS cause that's what everybody with a gun sounds like.
I'm kidding.
Of course they could have used a gun.
That would have been a great time to have a gun,
although the world is over populated and that guy was a fucking moron.
Any was doing something bad.
So that's a very hard thing.
That's,
that'd be a hard thing for gun owners,
you know,
cause they'd be like,
that sound bitch got what he deserved.
All right.
Family values.
You go to the zoo,
you paid to get in,
you don't sneak over.
And if you're going to sneak over,
always make sure you have a whole weapon on you.
I learned that from Ted Nugent.
All right?
Okay.
Then on top of that,
the guy that happened to wasn't flat.
So I don't have any feelings for him whatsoever.
They're taking enough stereotypes in there about gun owners.
Um,
I always like people try to make them out like they're all a bunch of fucking
morons.
You know,
it's like,
well then wouldn't they be like fucking accidentally shooting themselves all the
fucking time?
And don't even say they do.
Okay.
They don't,
that's just like the helicopters and I fly where everybody says they're fucking
dangerous because a bunch of people dying it.
Most people don't.
All right.
And the people that do do dumb shit and uh,
you know,
that's it.
So fuck it works.
If you do dumb shit,
you're going to have a fucking problem.
Um,
all right.
so you don't want to doing is,
I'm just,
I'm filibustering,
I'm waiting for my fucking me to get some of the,
uh,
the materials here that I need in order to complete my podcast.
There's usually some sort of a advertising and of course you guys right in to
the podcast.
I might have to hit pause here.
How much time have I done?
Oh my God.
Only 10 minutes in.
Gee.
Willikers Gee.
Willikers I feel like I fucking talked about everything already.
I mean,
God's sakes.
I have 50 more fucking minutes to go here.
Um,
oh,
I took my a wife and kid to go see a movie yesterday.
Uh,
I went to go see the,
what does that dog movie?
Patton.
Oswald Senate.
Kevin Hart is in a Tiffany Haddish.
All these great comedians that are in it.
Dog Movie
2019.
What is it called?
Oh for God sakes,
you advertisements only right outside my window.
All right.
I should have wrote Kevin Hart in there.
Kevin Hart,
dog movie
secret lives of pet
part two.
Yeah,
we went and got and saw that my daughter was so excited.
Right.
I was saying,
I just telling her that I was going to go,
I go,
I'm taking you to a movie tomorrow.
And she goes,
popcorn and a movie.
It's your favorite thing in the world.
She just sits there with this giant bag of popcorn.
You gotta watch a toddler though.
Cause they're like a puppy.
They'll eat until the,
literally they'd fucking belly.
So I had to keep taking the bag away from her.
MMM.
So she had like not,
not too much popcorn.
And then I gave her a couple of m and m's and that was it.
And,
uh,
she sat there and she enjoyed the whole movie.
So thanks to all the people that worked on that,
you know,
being a little bit in the animated world,
I can't imagine how much fucking work that is and how long it took you guys to
do that.
So thank you for the great hour and a half,
two hours of fucking entertainment.
And uh,
other than that,
all I did,
I just walked around.
They didn't smoke any cigars.
I was a,
I was a good boy last night and I was rewarded with good fucking spites thank
Christ.
So let's go,
let's go to the Google news.
This is what I do while I wait for my,
um,
when I went for my new shit to come in here,
let's go to Google news.
Okay.
As opposed to the mall where news that I was getting.
All right.
Donald Trump is up to his usual shit.
This is the funny thing ever.
Trump warns of a market crash,
quote,
market crash,
the likes of which has not been seen before.
If he loses the 2020 election.
But economists are worried he's causing a recession of his own.
He's causing it.
Don't the fucking assholes who really run it cause it.
United States President Donald Trump on Saturday warned without evidence of a
massive market crash.
If uh,
warned without evidence of a massive market crash.
If he's not reelected in 2020.
Dude,
have you ever seen a guy who loves to scream fire in a crowded movie theater?
Like this guy,
the Trump economy is setting records and has a long way up to go.
He said,
however,
if anyone but me takes over in 2020,
um,
I know that I know the competition very well.
There will be a market crash the likes of which has not been seen before.
Keep America great.
Do you realize how fucking selfish and irresponsible that is to tweet something
like that?
MMM.
Yeah.
I think that there's a market crash come in anyways.
I could say that without fucking known anything about at all.
I know is they just,
they just keep building these luxury high rise fucking apartment buildings
everywhere I go,
every fucking city I go to this just cranes and cranes and cranes building more
shit.
I don't know where all of these people are going to go.
Now this,
this conspiracy theory that the people that who really run the country are
trying to drive everyone into the city.
Now,
if they were building even remotely affordable housing,
I would believe that.
But what these fucking luxury high rise fucking things are doing is they're
actually forcing people out of the city.
MMM.
I told,
I told you before about the,
I always love bringing this up.
Like some of these buildings that they're building in,
uh,
New York City,
they are so high,
they actually have to pay a shadow tax because they block the sun from certain
parts of the park and the trees and the bushes and grass or resolve fucking
dying.
Um,
and then what kills me is they're actually up into the airspace commercial
airspace,
Bravo airspace,
which for Laguardia,
I dunno if it's Newark or what I think is Laguardia's airspace.
And,
uh,
it would just blow my mind that if you bought the penthouse and on a cloudy day
when you can barely sit outside your window,
you were in the same airspace.
Is Jumbo jets fucking flying by?
I mean,
I just don't know how the fuck do you relax at that point?
That's when you go downstairs to the lobby and,
and asked what the Wifi is down there and you just wait for that marine layer to
fucking burn off.
All right.
What am I talking about?
Buildings in Bravo airspace at this point.
All right,
this 15 minutes,
I'm going to fucking just hit pause here and I'm going to wait until I get all
of the materials I need and I will finish on with the podcast.
All right?
Yeah.
All right.
I'm back.
I got,
I got your questions.
I haven't gotten the reeds yet.
This is what happens when I fucking tried to do it so early,
but I was just sort of going around here,
did the Internet and um,
this thing here was talking about a,
I've led him Vladimir Putin.
Putin is Steven Seagal says,
arrested critic Alexi Noveli last novel knee,
hundreds more for taking part in an anticorruption protests.
Russian authorities arrested Alexi,
President Vladimir's phrase,
just critic along with hundreds of other protesters who took to the streets
following the arrest of a journalist's.
The mass arrests on Wednesday came after thousands of people participated in an
unauthorized rally in support of freedom of the press and investigative
journalism journalists,
Ivan Golan of who was arrested on drug charges,
on drug charges,
but later released after the government and that there was no evidence he
committed a crime.
Um,
it's unbelief.
I,
you know,
how familiar does that look?
I mean,
that's starting to be what it's like over here.
I know it's a little more extreme,
but like you can't fucking protests.
They let you,
you got to get a permit to protest and then when you do,
they have you fucking,
you're down like 20 blocks down and away from any sort of press coverage.
All our presses fucking seems to be owned by fucking 10 different people.
I Dunno,
I never understood the whole fucking end game of these cons.
Who just want to run the world.
It's like,
and then what?
What are you going to do?
What the fuck?
Why can't you just fucking just,
is it that hard to not be an asshole?
This is coming from an asshole.
I just don't fucking understand why you can't listen to your people.
I,
you know,
I do get it on some level of,
most people are mouth breathing morons and it's you,
you got to kind of have a firm hand.
I mean it was kid know where a bunch of children.
All right.
I can barely read.
I get sleepy when I try to read in depth shit.
So I mean I shouldn't be running anything.
I'm glad that there are people out there doing it.
But I guess my,
I guess my question is,
is that the only way to fucking do it
is the only way to run a country is to have secrets and tell everybody to shut
the fuck up and destroy anyone that questions your authority.
Because regardless of the form of government,
capitalism,
communism,
whatever,
I don't even know enough of them.
Show socialism.
Um,
that seems to be what they all do.
They all do the exact same fucking thing.
You know,
the illusion of choice,
the illusion of freedom,
you know,
but I mean you are free sort of.
I don't know.
I don't know how it works.
This has gotta be a Shit Day.
You just said they got all these guys saying I'm a corrupt piece of shit.
I got to go out and go fucking arrest this guy and then you know,
people are going to be slapping them around and stuff and then when we were
supposed to sit there reading and fucking pheasant or whatever the fuck rich
people eat,
you know,
they always need some weird bird.
Can't have chicken.
That's like too common.
They always have to have like a fucking goose or some you just going to sit
there and do that while these guys are fucking torture and somebody,
cause they had the audacity to say that maybe you were a little outside the
lines a few times.
You know,
I think that you could actually,
if people thought you were corrupt,
you could actually stay in power if we just admitted it to open like you know
what?
Yeah,
I got a little out of line a couple of times,
but you know,
if you look historically,
this is how it's done.
What say we changed that,
so what are your top complaints about me?
I will work on it and I'll free all these journalists and from here on out I
will welcome their criticisms and I will try to be a better leader now at that
point,
even the fucking people you jailed,
well they probably don't trust you at that point I would think would be willing
to give you a second chance.
I just don't understand why every single fucking time you got to go is Patrice
O'Neal used to say,
you've got to take out the fucking goat hand,
put it on the back of people's necks and just start fucking kicking the shit out
of everybody.
It's got to be it.
Is there a,
is there a country out there?
I don't know.
I don't,
I didn't get that vibe when I was in Iceland.
You know,
there are countries out there where I don't feel like they necessarily have to
do that,
but uh,
who knows?
Who knows that it's a depressing,
it's why don't fucking pay attention to it.
It's all,
it's above me.
I don't understand why I,
I'll say it till the day.
I just do not understand how war is still legal.
I understand somebody literally comes in and fucking attacks you.
You got,
you got to fight fire with fire,
but just as far as just like,
hey,
we want to do this.
Well,
we're going to do that.
All right now we're going to try to kill more of your people.
Then you can kill of ours and whoever kills more people is right.
That's the best we can do.
I have a wireless headphone set,
but we can still go to war.
All right.
Let me read some of the reads here for this weekend and these aren't the
advertising.
This is,
I'm going to go straight to the fucking emails here at my 19 year old daughter
introduced me to you about three months ago.
My 19 year old daughter,
uh,
introduced me to you and I am a big fan.
What I love about you is that my daughter and I can enjoy your comedy together
and I get to enjoy the references that bring back my childhood.
I'm 52.
Well,
I'm 51.
There you go.
Look at this.
Everybody thinks I don't have any sort of a female demographic.
I got a 19 year old kid introducing me to where?
Mom.
Perfect.
Uh,
and you explain the references to my daughter this week,
Phil Negro and Ken Stabler.
If you're going to read a book,
Go back and read Jack Tatum's.
They call me a assassin and I've already read that.
It will remind you just how brutal football was.
Yo.
Yeah,
the NFL was,
you know,
I read that one.
I read 'em
bye.
They call.
Uh,
was he on a Hollywood Henderson's book?
I read a lot of them.
I read these desks.
The type of shit I read.
I read the autobiography use of everyone who wrote one in guns and roses,
um,
vesa kind of reading.
I do.
And then every once in a while I'll actually do something that's actually,
I'll read like a,
yeah,
you know,
a difficult book that isn't a book about some famous person's life,
but that Ken Stabler one is definitely on my radar.
In fact,
I enjoyed reading in between setups on the movie so much.
You know what?
I might go to a fucking amazon.com right now.
See if I can,
if I can fucking find that book,
I'm going to go.
I went to see Ken Stabler Book,
Ken Stabler and I got a water now before you comes by every copy.
Ken Stabler
auto by a Griffey are right.
There we go.
Come on.
What do you got there?
Oh,
it's just called snake.
Are you kidding me?
That's all it's called.
Snake Badass is by John The legend of the snake.
John Madden does the forward or sound,
look at all these fucking books right here.
Snake by Ken Stabler,
$4 and 19 cents.
Why is Amazon 1721 cause it is that the drone charge?
Well,
what the fuck come on.
Snake.
The legendary life of Ken Stabler.
Yeah.
The first in depth biography,
one of the most talented and infamous legends to play in the national football
league.
The life and times of pro football's first bad boy fame is not the first bad
boy.
Famed Oakland Raiders quarterback,
Ken Stabler.
Ken.
This snake.
Oh,
isn't that lovely?
I'm going to fucking,
here's another Raiders one.
Cheating is encouraged.
Hey,
hard nose history of the 1970s Raiders.
I mean,
who the fuck doesn't want to read?
Look at these books.
All my God.
I found my part of the library
countdown to Superbowl.
How the 68 69 New York jets delivered on Joe name is promise.
This is all you do is you just start clicking on these fucking things.
Okay.
All the way.
Joe Nemeth beyond Broadway.
Joe.
Yeah.
Cousins of wills,
Johnny Unitas,
Don Shula and the rise of the modern NFL.
Oh my God.
I would read all of these.
These are the grid.
Bob,
uh,
Bob Greasy book,
Big Fella.
Babe Ruth's in the world he created,
this is Johnny Unitas.
Not for long.
The life and career of the NFL athlete.
The 1969,
Baltimore 58 Baltimore Colts.
Oh my God.
Raymond Berry.
This is,
this is it right here.
All these people like me saying,
I don't like to fucking read.
I will read.
I always read all of those fucking books.
At least the basketball ones was bill Simmons.
When I read his book on the history of basketball,
Jesus Christ,
that guy would be like,
it's like an ric.
Robbie's in Eric ferns stuns book.
Like he'd be acquitted.
I didn't even know they wrote a book.
Um,
all right.
Men Dying Young.
Hey Billy stat whore.
Uh,
figured you'd find this interesting.
It shows how men are dying in their prime at an increasing rate.
92,000 a year,
twice as many as the Korean and Vietnam wars combined,
which is funny because almost three quarters of all health and lifestyle related
progress products are marketed towards women proves many of your points.
Happy Father's Day.
Um,
well I think it's also marketed towards women because they're allowed to take
care of themselves.
You know what I mean?
Guys have like a fear of going to the doctor.
And you know what that fear is is because you haven't gone in so long.
So if you're a young guy,
I recommend bright.
Now getting a doctor going and get a physical,
you know,
99.9%,
you're going to be all right.
And you know,
if you're not,
it's great you went in because then they can fucking maybe save you.
But if you go in early,
it's like back in the day,
like the getting,
getting tested for HIV aids,
the first test was fucking brutal cause that was your entire career.
Everything you fucking did and you just sat this sweating bullets.
Then the next time they had to get tested like fucking once a year and then
you're only worried about maybe one or two incidents,
you know,
you'd always lie to yourself,
I'm always going to work.
I mean,
only fuck up.
Right.
All right.
Uh,
so I highly recommend that.
All right.
The real gender gap in heart disease
because I'm a guy.
I took a poll at the recent family barbecue heart disease who has it worse men
or women?
I asked the answers came prickly.
My mother in law and sister in law said women,
my father in law,
arms crossed,
said confidently men,
um,
my mother in law remembered hearing about how heart disease affected women more
than men during the February American heart association go red for women.
I gotta be honest with you.
When I hear people dropping a heart attacks,
it's usually a guy.
Uh,
anyways,
apparently the message wasn't heard by the men at this family gathering.
They were moved by stories of men,
fathers,
brothers,
friends.
They knew who died from heart disease.
We are taught that facts should Trump feelings,
evidence should Trump anecdotes.
And at first glance it would appear the men are in touch with their feelings.
It is the mission.
What is that mission of advocacy organizations like the a h a to raise awareness
charts like this one are wildly,
yeah,
discernment and used in countless presentations on the topic.
I don't even can't even read that word.
Well I thought this is going to be an easy article.
I don't know what they're talking about.
The graph demonstrates that over the last few decades,
the number of women dying from heart disease has been significantly higher than
men from heart disease in the year 2000 alone.
The gap is the most impressive with 70,000 more women dying than men.
The problem with the chart is that it's completely misleading.
Mortality in the case is best judged by death rates that take into account age
and population at risk.
Dude,
I gotta be honest with you.
I know a number of guys who've had heart attacks and who died of heart attacks.
I don't know.
I've never known a woman to die of a heart attack.
Okay.
I Dunno.
That's weird.
I feel like women get breast cancer and guys get heart attacks.
That's Kinda how it,
then we get fucking prostate cancer.
MMM.
That seems like they,
they actually,
what I was that person trying to just say the opposite and the email,
cause it seemed like they would argue on the other side.
I have no idea.
All I know is I have a doctrine now when I get fucking checked out,
that's what I do.
Cause I had a buddy of mine who is 49 years old,
getting on an elliptical was in better shape than me and had a fatal heart
attack.
So,
um,
and he was never overweight or anything like that.
So sometimes it's just like you're a
okay,
you know,
your genetics and then also like the shit that's in food.
Who the fuck knows who the fuck knows?
Sometimes my paranoia,
I think that they let you know,
it's usually just because of money.
But I and I,
but I like the politicians let what happened to our food supply happen because
they knew that they couldn't tell people to just stop having as many kids so we
can taper off the population itself.
Maybe they're taking things into their own hands.
I have no idea.
All right.
Apple store.
I bet they have a beautiful fucking organic garden for everybody at a certain
level of power being old school shit.
All right.
Apple Story.
Hey.
Oh,
William Billboard.
Uh,
you may want to think twice about taking your apple products apple store.
Well,
too late now.
I recently saw this video.
I thought you might find it interesting.
Just something to consider.
Uh,
apple genius bar is scamming customers.
What?
They didn't charge me any money and they fixed it.
MMM.
Now I got to watch a 12 minute.
Oh,
they're talking about their labor charges.
Well,
I'm glad somebody put this out here because they were on their best behavior.
When I went there,
I showed up and they said,
William,
we have you down.
We will call you in six minutes.
And I sat and I listened to music and write.
When I was worried did they forget about me to people came over.
What's the problem?
They figured it out.
They fucking handle this shit in 20 minutes it was over.
I'm never clicking on anything ever again in the mall where it was gone.
It was really bothering me that that was on my fucking,
to the point.
I didn't even use my laptop for like three days.
I was so fucking pissed.
It's like I don't watch porn anymore.
MMM.
I don't booze anymore.
I've totally cleaned up my fucking life trying to,
you know,
be a better person here and within.
Yeah.
I still end up getting a fucking,
if I was watching porn and be like,
well,
you know,
I played the game,
what are you going to do?
I mean,
you know,
you're going to get into a knife fight.
You're going to get fucking cut.
What do you think's going to happen?
But I was sitting there being a goddamn saint and I still got one.
Very,
very upsetting.
Um,
all right,
let's read another one here.
What do we got here?
Okay.
Single girl helped love when the ladies right in.
All right.
Hello Billy matchmaker.
I'm a longtime female listener in need of advice.
If you are Nia,
have a few minutes to help out.
I'm a 35 year old woman living in New York City.
I own a two family townhouse in Brooklyn.
Ah,
you're crushing it.
She goes on and I'm a land.
I'm a land lady.
That's awesome.
Good for you.
That thing.
We'll pay you your whole life.
Um,
I have a curvy and voluptuous yet healthy size 12 figure.
I don't know what that means.
I know you're curvy.
You're a bigger girl.
I hit my home gym on the regular and go to therapy once a week.
I got great relationships with supporting and loving friends and family.
I absolutely love music and cook pretty well.
I run my own small business that is successful and as you can tell,
I have a great sense of humor.
Been listening to your podcast since 2011.
All right.
What's not like?
Uh,
I've done a lot of work on myself over the years to break habits of dating guys
who are fun in real life,
but on paper have Peter Pan Syndrome and are essentially adult children.
I'm ready for the real thing.
There you go.
I was that guy for a long time.
The problem is I'm having a hard time finding the real thing.
I work in the fashion industry.
The majority of my colleagues are straight women or gay guys.
Any men after that are married or 23 years old,
23 year old interns.
I've asked my,
uh,
friends,
men and women in successful relationships,
if they could play matchmaker for me,
but none of them trust the guy,
their guy friends enough to get with me and not to not screw me over.
Yeah.
It's hard anyways because I'm focused on a healthier lifestyle.
I'm not interested in meeting uh,
a guy at a bar at 2:00 AM now you're doing all the right things.
You're right.
Guy is coming,
you stay in single,
you're working on yourself.
Um,
I would suggest before you get through the rest of this is getting some sort of
extra curricular activity then involves interacting with healthy people.
MMM.
Some sort of sports league thing.
Uh,
maybe some sort of volunteer work just somewhere where you're going to hopefully
meet decent people.
Just get into that circle cause you're not going to meet a decent guy at 2:00 AM
in a bar.
Uh,
anyways,
I'm not in Aa or 12 steps.
I just like to wake up early and not have a bloated face.
A online dating is okay,
but most people on here just looking for hookups.
Absolutely.
I'm not approved by any means.
I've had more than my fair share of action living in the dorm room that is NYC.
So the question is,
can you suggest ways for in New York City for me to meet guys who have their
shit together,
who are looking for the real thing?
Perhaps if one of your listeners hears this and is interested.
No,
absolutely.
Well,
I think I gave you the suggestions that I have a 51 year old man who is not been
single in,
I dunno,
15 years.
So,
um,
I do know that when you decide like I am not settling and I'm just going to stay
single until the right person comes along.
Uh,
that's when most people meet the person that they're supposed to be with.
You don't force it,
you don't force it.
And you know,
you go through the holidays alone,
which is fine,
you know,
hang out with other single people and there's light,
there's a friend,
then you can also be,
you know,
other parts of your life.
Uh,
do well like your business because you're not distracted by,
I thought we weren't going out and I,
you know,
and that's what it sounds like when you're with the wrong person.
Okay.
When you with the right person,
like,
Hey,
I thought we were going out tonight and be like,
Oh fuck yeah,
let's do it.
I actually like you.
Uh,
well good luck,
good luck.
You're doing all the right things.
You're still young.
You still your prime,
you got the whole fucking thing ahead of you.
You're crushing it.
Um,
I,
yeah,
I would try to,
you know,
look at Time Out New York and shit like that.
There's a,
there's things that like decent people do and I don't know what they are.
Cause I'm one of these filthy entertainers.
I'm in the,
I'm in the nightclub scene.
You don't want to be around this sweetie.
Okay.
I'll tell you it's a rough one.
Um,
there's gotta be something,
something going on in the park,
you know,
those people back in the day who like,
let's,
let's start a roller blading group.
Like those people there,
those are decent people.
Um,
I dunno,
I just realized,
I don't know where the decent people are.
Uh,
accidentally cut someone.
I love how this word is coming into the lexicon.
Cocked is like a big fucking internet word.
Everybody loves using that word now.
Uh,
hey Billy Budd fucker.
The more soft mark,
the funnier.
Uh,
hey bill.
I just found out about a situation I become involved in and would like to hear
your opinion on the matter.
I'm a 20 year old college student in Pittsburgh and find myself involved with
the lady during the school year.
We weren't dating or anything,
but she would read regularly,
come over and we would hook up.
The girl is really hot and the sex was good and all,
but eventually I broke things off and started seeing a different girl.
Oh,
I'm seeing a different girl.
Okay.
Every now and again,
this girl would hit me up to hang up,
but we never did because I was interested in another girl.
And even though I'm no longer seeing the new girl,
this,
this other girl is still hits me up from time to time.
Uh,
however,
I recently found out that this broad had a boyfriend in the entire time.
Oh,
the entire time we were fucking Jesus Christ.
I know someone who got the shit kicked out of him one time because of that.
They had no idea,
had no idea and was sitting in the car with her and this guy just fucking yanked
him out and beat the shit out of him.
Of course,
it's his fault.
Right.
Uh,
I kind of feel like a piece of shit knowing I was fucking someone else's girl.
Yeah.
But you didn't know because I wouldn't willingly hookup are even hit on a girl
who was in a relationship.
Uh,
I would just like your opinion on whether I should feel bad about having sex
with the girl,
this girl dozens of time.
And you think I should reach out to the guy to let them know how much of a whore
or his girlfriend is a,
I would love to hear what the lovely Nia feels about this as well.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Um,
well there's no reason for you to feel guilty because you didn't know you were
doing anything wrong.
Uh,
reach out to the guy that that's your decision.
I would,
I personally would just walk.
I never tried to get involved in shit like that.
Cause
you know what,
if the person doesn't believe you,
then they know who the fuck you are and then you're dealing with some fucking
crazy shit.
I Dunno,
I have no,
uh,
I'll let you make that decision yourself,
but you shouldn't feel guilty because you didn't know.
If you go back and do it again,
then you should feel guilty.
Um,
all right.
That was an easy one.
Okay.
What else we got here?
I don't even miss it.
Might done.
Ah,
Jesus,
another 22.
Okay.
Uh,
my wife and I have been together for 13 years,
10 years,
married and almost 11,
uh,
10 years.
Married almost 11.
All right.
Whenever we argue,
oh,
this is wife
wife's things,
wife's things.
My body is aggressive.
What wife thinks my body is aggressive.
I don't even know what.
Anyways,
hello couplets.
Bill.
My wife and I have been together for 13 years,
10 years,
married almost 11 whenever we argue,
she accuses me of yelling,
which I'm not.
I sometimes proceed to show her the difference between the way I'm talking and
yelling.
She then chain changes to say that I'm not yelling,
but I'm sounding aggressive.
I don't know what that means,
and I've asked her what does she mean?
She's talking about your tone.
She says,
because I have a deep voice and a big guy,
six three to 60 that I come across as aggressive.
This pisses me off because I cannot control my size.
To me,
she's saying if I was a smaller guy with the same voice,
I would not sound aggressive.
I've gone so far as to argue my point with the gay voice to sound like
aggressive.
This that's you did that.
He goes,
just pisses her off even more.
I've walked away so I don't get pulled into any arguments.
This pisses her off even more.
I don't know what to do.
How do I control something I have no control of?
I feel like she just wants someone to argue with and I'm forced to take the
bait.
That's what I feel.
She just wants to argue.
Then I made to feel guilty for my size and voice by being labeled aggressive.
How do I a not make my large football players size body not seem aggressive
during an argument and be walk away from the argument without pissing her off
even more.
Thanks and go fuck yourself,
uh,
while dreaming of the 2010,
2011 cup run.
Oh,
that's what you meant by couplets.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
dude,
this is what's going on.
She is manipulating the living shit out of you to win arguments.
All right?
So what you have to do in an argument is you have to not raise your voice.
This is what the,
if you want to win with the woman,
you have to not raise your voice.
You have to,
you have to say what,
what they did and how it made you feel,
and then you have to listen to them.
And when they're done yapping,
okay.
If they tried to warm their way out of it and you know,
they're trying to worm their way out of it.
You can't accuse him of it.
You have to sit there and say like,
okay,
I heard what you say.
I don't understand how that pertains to what it is.
And I'm saying,
yeah,
and you just stay there.
And eventually if you with a fucking adult,
they're going to apologize.
All right?
You shouldn't be yelling anyways.
I'm trying to stop doing it.
I bet it was doing so great.
And I dunno the stress of being on the road and I can't go to therapy now.
I have,
I've kind of fucking,
I've gone back a little bit,
but I was able to see that and now I'm kind of focusing back on not yelling,
but,
um,
I think,
uh,
the fact that you have the balls to have done the gay voice to your wife,
um,
shows me that you're not afraid of her and she doesn't have your balls in the
purse.
So I would just,
you know,
I would talk to her about this while you're not in an argument,
I would just sit her down and say,
we need to talk.
She'd be like a cat.
All right?
And then you sit down and just say,
listen,
when you're in an arg and in a relationship,
you're going to have disagreements.
Okay.
The way I air my disagreements doesn't seem to be working for you.
So I need you to tell me the proper way that I,
I,
you know,
so then you get her to commit.
If I sit down and not raise my voice,
will I then be heard and not be criticized?
Right?
So then,
and then just play by her fucking rules and she'll think that she's winning.
But then what she's done is she's eliminated her ability to avoid what it is
that you're saying.
And just talk about,
you know,
the way you're,
you,
you gestured with your arm,
how low your voice or high your voice was.
And that takes all of that off the table.
And now you just have to deal with the point that you're trying to make.
And a,
I would give that a try and um,
hopefully that works.
And if it doesn't and she still just finds a million things to bitch about,
then I would consider moving on.
Because you know,
who wants to be in a relationship with someone who's not an adult and you're
just signing up to be bitched at 24 fucking seven for the rest of your fucking
life.
And honestly,
who the fuck wants that?
Nobody wants that.
Okay.
And uh,
if you,
if you sit down with her and you have this conversation and then the next time
you guys argue,
if you followed by what she's saying would not be aggressive and all of that,
and she still has a problem with it,
then you advance the conversation saying like,
listen,
this is not adult behavior.
Okay,
I'm not signing up.
I don't want to,
if this is the way you're going to be,
every time we have a disagreement that no matter what I'm doing,
it's not going to be about what I'm saying.
It's going to be about the way that I presented it.
Um,
then I'm never going to be heard in this relationship and that's not what I'm
looking for.
So what do you want to do?
Say thanks is saying that back up with me.
I'm saying if you don't start acting like an adult,
I am going to break up with you.
I'm going to move on.
This is going get old.
Okay.
I know I'm not right 100% of the time,
but I know a good 30%,
35 on a good month.
I am right.
And I'm just not seeing the data's not showing that the,
the,
the results here.
All right.
I would go that route.
Okay.
All right,
that's it.
Uh,
for the questions.
Now I'm waiting for the advertising method link like three of these fucking
things together.
Yeah.
Ah,
right now I'm back.
I'm back waiting time for the reeds here.
Good Lord.
This has been a real disjointed podcasts.
I apologize.
Simply stay safe.
Everybody.
You know,
10 years ago getting home security stunk.
It felt like companies went out of their way to make your life miserable with
long contracts.
She never knew what you'd pay and they made your,
you rewire your whole home.
Well,
I must've sucked.
This was considered normal then simply saved,
comes along and totally transformed home security.
They did everything right.
They built a better system and they treat your rights simply safe stands up to
unexpected to the unexpected from burglars to blizzards to blackouts.
All the bees they got it covered.
Simply safe has 24,
seven professional monitoring and police dispatch everything to keep your home
safe.
It's a PC,
mag readers choice and a wire cutter top pick and at one scene at editor's
choice twice,
not once,
but Dwight and simply safe makes your life easier.
Uh,
there's no contract,
no hidden fees and no rewiring your home.
3 million people are protected by simply safe already and not one of them is
locked into a contract.
Um,
check out simply safe for yourself.
Visit simply safe bird.com all in capitals,
the bird part.
Uh,
you'll get free shipping and free returns plus a 60 day money back trial that
simply safe bur.com so they know that I sent you.
Simply Save bird.com and lastly,
but not leastly.
Uh,
look who it is everybody.
It's all stamps.com,
stamps.com everybody,
you know,
no one really has time to go to the post office.
You're busy.
You got time for all that traffic parking.
Who's got time for all that traffic,
parking,
lugging all your mail and packages.
It's a real hassle,
man.
That's why you need stamps.com one of the most popular time saving tools for
small businesses.
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the post office.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the US post office right to your
computer.
Uh,
whether you're in a small office setting,
sending invoices or online or an online seller,
shipping out products,
or even a warehouse,
sending thousands of packages a day,
stamps.com can help,
can handle all of that with ease.
Right now my can get a special offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without any longterm commitment.
Just go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in bird.
That's stamps.com.
Enter bar.
All right.
That was painless,
Huh?
That was painless with the reeds over there.
Um,
so this has been the battle.
The battle has been not to fight the battle of the bulge here.
I have to eat.
Well,
I think we wrap on August 9th.
So I'm going to go hit the fucking elliptical again.
And um,
I got to remember my knee pad.
I'm at that age now.
I got precise or whatever in my fucking left knee and my,
and my left shoulder.
My right shoulder finally feels good.
That was the one that was always the problem with the fucking rotator,
where we're tated cuff there,
whatever the hell you call it now.
My right,
one's all fucked up so I don't know what to do.
I remember thinking like,
ah,
you know,
getting old.
It's just like,
it's like a mentality.
And I just stayed active and I was still thinking like I'm still running up
flights of stairs.
I'm almost 50 years old.
And then just one day fucking got the old right there,
Fred three out of four of my major joints.
So now it's becoming all,
what the hell I'm eating?
I don't know.
It's the worst.
I was reading that Howard stern thing as I was saying that,
that um,
the uh,
article in rolling stone,
it was this wide combination of it was like,
you know,
inspiring to see somebody that's trying to like change and become a new person,
a better version of who they used to be or whatever.
And then it was also depressing with just talking about people getting old and
people fucking dying and all of that shit.
Just,
uh,
you know,
I got it.
Well,
how do you guys want to go?
What you gotta you gotta pick the fucking dying in your sleep as the way to go.
You ran your nineties you know,
you had a little cup of cocoa and a cookie or something like that right before
you went to bed.
And you just fucking let you get people when they get really old,
super old,
they're ready to die.
You know,
my grandmother was like that.
She lived to almost be 105 years old and she outlived she was,
she went through three sets of friends.
Can you imagine that?
Just think everybody,
you know and love is dead.
And then you get another group of people that you know and love and then they
die and then you get the third set and they start dying.
And as you'd get to,
at some point you gotta be sitting there going like,
all right,
am I a vampire this whole fucking time?
And I didn't realize it.
How many people usually start dropping 60s and 70s so you live 30 years beyond
that,
you know you're going to have to rebuild the franchise.
A couple of times.
Here's another thing too.
When you die,
young people care.
People show up,
you get a great funeral.
The older you get,
the less people that knew you,
they're gone.
I'm trying to think,
the optimal age to die.
Like at what point?
Like,
like if they were graphing
like a great funeral as far as people giving a shit,
because you want people to be devastated when you die.
Right?
You don't want people to just speak.
They're going through the motions.
You want people to be emotionally affected,
but as you out live everybody or you live long enough that all your friends are
old.
That even when they go up there,
they have a lifetime of memories that is going to be up there.
Like where like good fella and fall asleep,
like fucking that dude on the Simpsons.
MMM.
I would say sometime in a,
once you get over 70
once you get over 70 I think that that's,
you lived too low,
too long for a good funeral,
you know what I mean?
As far as people really caring,
you know,
that's when you start getting to wow our,
was he 75 that's a nice run,
man.
I take 75 can't pitch at that.
You know,
people start saying shit like that,
you know,
anything younger than even the 60s now people are like,
oh so young,
60 you know,
67 is dead.
It's just not a long time.
Like people need to see that seven.
Once you get in the seven and eights,
forget about it.
Like no one gives a shit,
you know,
nineties you know,
I dunno.
I'm trying to think like,
hey,
I every time somebody dies in their nineties oh his grandmother died.
Really?
Yeah,
she was 91 [inaudible] 91 can't get too upset.
I mean,
I know it's just grand five grand mother.
You can't get too upset about that.
Right.
I wonder if that's what the doctors say to you.
If you make it into your nineties and you went to the hospital and you're on
your deathbed and they were like,
all right,
listen,
this is it.
But uh,
you know,
you can't get too mad at that.
I mean 91 you lived in every decade.
Just think of all this shit that you saw.
You know I'm in Christ.
When you were a little member,
the member or your friend who got hit with the rock from the slingshot fucking
debt,
there's been like 12 presidents since that happened.
I don't know what the fuck you're complaining about.
Like nobody has any sympathy for you.
It's like when Bob hope died,
if Bob hope died like 40 years before he did,
if he died in his sixties like it would've been,
it would've borderline Ben.
Like when,
when Reagan died,
when they parade in his body all over the fucking country.
Right.
I mean as far as what a giant that guy was,
but he lived so fucking long.
There was nobody left.
You know,
I'm trying to think of great funerals.
Elvis had a great one.
All those white caddies.
Reagan had a great one.
Reagan had a better one than Elvis.
I'm trying to think of the best funerals as far as like,
okay,
if I'm going to die and I want everybody to give a shit.
As far as people giving a shit.
Oh it does.
It does.
There's one for you,
right?
Top your top five public figure funerals of all time.
I got Elvis,
Ronald Reagan.
You see
those are the two that come to mind.
Oh I got to,
I can't pick a top five.
It's gotta be an athlete or something.
Right
singer or a politician.
You'd think Michael Jackson's would have been bigger.
Michael Jackson.
Cause you know what,
by then,
by the time he died,
there was like the online response,
you know what I mean?
All these people made like these dance videos.
So that was amazing because that came,
that was like around the fucking world's reaction.
So in a way his was the biggest,
but like I didn't see like a lot of,
maybe it wasn't like televised.
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
This is a nice morbid subject to try to end the podcast on.
Um,
all right,
well I think I've done a bottle now.
This podcast might be a little bit short,
but it is father's day today.
And,
uh,
I got to hang out with the wife and Kiddo and I got some lines to learn from my
scene tomorrow.
Look at this.
We're already halfway through June.
The shoot is going to fly by June is flying by and make sure you get out there.
You enjoy this summer.
Okay.
Make sure you put on your sunblock.
By the way.
My head's peeling and had to do this scene outside in the backyard for the
entire fucking day.
And they were giving me this umbrella to stand underneath.
And it wasn't until the end of the day that I was kinda thinking like,
well,
this umbrella was designed to stop rain,
not block out the fucking Sun.
And,
uh,
I cooked my head.
I didn't overcook it all right.
But it was definitely done.
The little Purdue of and stuff and roaster,
that thing popped and it was done.
And,
uh,
my head hurt for like three days and now it's just like,
that's gross.
It's like fucking peelings fucking disgusting.
So that's what,
that was my big father's day wish.
What do you want for fall is father's day.
I'm like Aloe Vera.
So I will be staying out of the sun.
Uh,
thank you to the west side comedy club and the comedy cellar forgetting me up.
this weekend I had such a fucking great time and I'm loving standup more than
ever and I'm,
I'm actually really enjoying the crowds here in New York.
I think I cracked the code and figure out how to tease them in a way that gets
them out of that stupid,
you know,
post me too.
Hashtag I need to take everything super seriously at this comedy show.
And also to remind them too that they didn't hire a comic for a private show
that they're adults and they went out to a nightclub.
Okay.
It's a fucking relax.
All right,
that's it.
I don't know who to cheer on at this point.
Hockey's done.
Football's done.
Basketball's done.
Go Red Sox.
Kinda the middle of the pack.
Little over 500 Yankees are crushing it and they know you have their regulars.
I know they just uh,
got a big time free agent.
They always do shit.
Right.
And so I'm going to be watched your baseball this year to see if the Yankees can
win it this year.
And they'll have gone,
you know,
they'll have one,
one in this decade,
keeping this streak alive since the 80s.
They want twenties,
30s,
forties,
50s,
60,
76 decades in a row.
Six decades in a row.
They went over in the eighties.
Now they got the nineties,
uh,
2000.
And then if they get the teens,
there'll be halfway to their record again.
It's fucking amazing.
And look at the Lakers stocking up.
Like you knew they would get an Anthony Davis.
We'll see how that works out out there.
Um,
I guess we were possibly in the running,
but like,
I don't know,
we just,
we don't play the free agency game to,
well we don't do it as well as the Lakers.
Do you know,
we did it well with the big three.
That's the one and only time I feel like we really got it fucking right.
But then,
um,
I dunno,
the Kyrie Irving thing didn't work out.
I mean he played well for us.
We won games and shit.
But like at the end of the day,
it's all about winning a championship with us.
Hang on.
I've got to let people know.
Hey,
how are you?
What's up guys?
I'm still recording.
How is dance class?
Was it fun?
Yeah.
What'd you do?
Oh,
look at that.
Good for you.
Can you say happy father's Day.
Dot.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
All right,
let me wrap this up and we're going to hang it in.
There you go.
Alright.
That's the,
uh,
that's the podcast here for this week.
Uh,
so yeah,
so I think,
um,
I don't know how many more years do you think Lebron has?
It's weird.
You always seems tired,
but I dunno.
Then it comes to the playoffs and he fucking go.
If he gets there,
you know,
it's the first time he hasn't made it obviously in like fucking,
I don't know how many years,
but uh,
I think he's got plenty left in the tank.
So I'd say the Lakers are looking pretty good,
even though they had a trade away.
All of their team.
I want to see,
uh,
you know,
I'll be interesting to see what's going to happen.
What about the fucking warriors?
Jesus Christ,
man,
they lose Katie and then they,
I keep wanting to call him fucking clay Matthews,
Klay Thompson,
just fucking too devastating injuries and they might be out for the entire
fucking year.
It's unreal.
And then the Lakers fucking load up and just like that they're right back in it,
you know,
it's fucking unreal.
Kills me.
Kills me as a Celtics Fan.
But I gotta admit it sucks when their bed,
cause Celtics Lakers is the best shit you're going to watch.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on you on Wednesday.
Thursday.
Sorry.